hi I'm Erik Bosse and Dave of Thrones
final season has revealed its first
official look an HBO countdown trailer
showed lots of footage from last season
but included this new shot of Jon Snow
it states a stark hugging it out sure
it's only like three seconds but that's
plenty for a junkie like me just think
it 24 frames per second that's about a
72 hole still images do zooming enhance
on Plus the hundreds of pages of subtext
that Kit Harington and so if you turn to
must have kept in mind for these facial
tics there's a lot to milk here so pull
up a stool grab some dry cereal this
metaphor got kind of gross let's talk
about this footage spoiler warning in
case I get anything to write about
season 8 okay so in this shot we can see
Jon Snow clearly in Winterfell embracing
Sansa Stark now when we last saw Jon at
the end of season seven he was on a boat
returning to Winterfell from that summit
with Cersei and Dany and all the other
key players in King's Landing and let's
not forget both sex with his aunt really
regretting that uh milk reference right
about now
meanwhile Sansa had just solidified her
position in power at Winterfell after a
season of waffling under the influence
of Petyr Baelish and the surprise return
of her siblings bran and Arya Sansa
decisively cut ties with Littlefinger
and restored the ties within the stark
family and remembered two people who
know the truth about Jon and Danny's
real family tree relationship with each
other are also currently in Winterfell
bran and Samwell Tarly the finale ended
with them comparing notes and realizing
the truth about Jon's parents Rhaegar
and Lyanna so all of this context is
baked into this embrace between Jon and
Sansa I'm assuming this will be in the
first episode of season 8 and it kind of
evokes that memorable reunion embrace
between Sansa and Johnna Castle black in
season six
but by comparison this hug is a lot
colder look closely it's a it's his eyes
they dart over to someone else off
camera shooting what looks to me like a
pretty frosty glare so who is Sansa
looking at well it could be Daenerys who
would probably be joining John in this
moment and we know say it's a publicly
discouraged John from going to meet
Danny distrusting the Dragon Queen it's
the same kind of lunatic her father was
have you forgotten what happened to our
grandfather the Mad King invited him to
King's Landing and roasted him alive he
is here to reclaim the Iron Throne and
the Seven Kingdoms the North is one of
those Seven Kingdoms this isn't an
invitation it's a trap it's a trap just
imagine how icy sits is gonna feel if
John walks in to Winterfell holding
Daenerys his hand and how much bran and
Sam will puke good thing Sam got that
experience cleaned up messes in the
Citadel
now some Watchers have said that John's
hair and the shot might be braided into
two braids which would match Danny's
Jayhawk I guess that would be exactly
what a guy would do when he you know
brings home his unwanted girlfriend to
meet the family oh hey man this is my
Sun and stars
and she eats horse hearts and we braided
our hair together to be like those
avatar things she's my what but I don't
think John's hair is braided here it's
just a trick and a light looks a little
wet and pulled back in this standard bun
that we've seen before now it's also
possible that Santa's looking at Arya
here the reunion between John and Arya
has been waited for for years perhaps
the final major character reunion that
this story is held out on John and Arya
have only shared one scene together way
back in the second episode of the series
back when they were both babies it was a
pivotal goodbye between the two black
sheep of the stark family during which
John gifted her her sword needle
both characters left that moment to
pursue wide-ranging journeys that
fundamentally changed them so to see
these two protagonists face each other
again is going to pretend a pretty
interesting dynamic will John distrust
Arya as a vengeance obsessed rogue
threatening to destabilize his
precarious but necessary alliance with
his former foes will Arya distrust John
for bringing this Targaryen interloper
into their home for bending the knee to
a Dragon Rider much like their ancestor
Torrens stark did to John and Danny's
ancestor Aegon the Conqueror and
speaking of dragons that could also be
of course what senses looking at here
this would be the first time Sansa or
anyone
Phil would have laid eyes on dragons and
drogon and Rhaegar would certainly
present a pretty spectacular sight no I
wouldn't describe Sansa's look here as
aw or fear my best guess for her
internal monologue in this moment is you
know Dothraki brother or maybe I can't
believe I'm hugging someone who trusted
Cersei Lannister and yeah those eyes
might also be pointed that Tyrion
Lannister her once husband a man she
must know some pretty complicated
feelings for interestingly her stare
here reminds me a lot of that final shot
of Tyrion in season 7 when he gave a
similar look of concern as he realized
the developments in Jon and Danny's
relationship
I can imagine some nonverbal moment
between Sanson Tyrion in the scene as
both of these cunning political
tactician z-- share empathy for each
other
for both having to play second fiddle to
their more impulsive rulers but the
question I have for you is who do you
think Sansa is looking at here comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on Twitter and Instagram I da boss
for some stuff I'm working on that I
think you guys will really enjoy know
lately I've been focused a lot on Marvel
stuff but I'm just as big a fan for Game
of Thrones and Star Wars and everything
else so stay tuned for more updates
there like this video share it around
subscribe to new rockstars where we can
stretch three seconds a game of Thrones
footage into something that will keep
you watching for a hundred times the
length of that magic